the idea of eliminating poverty
is a great goal
i don't think anyone in this room would
disagree
what worries me
is when politicians with money
and charismatic rock stars
use the words it all just sounds so
so simple
i've got no bucket of money today
and i've got no policy to release
and i certainly haven't got a guitar
i'll leave that to others
but i do have an idea and that idea is
called housing for health
housing for health works with poor
people it works in the places where they
live
and the work is done to improve their
health
over the last 28 years
this tough grinding dirty work
has been done by literally thousands of
people around australia and more
recently overseas
and their work has proven
that focused design
can improve even the poorest living
environments
it can improve health and it can play a
part in reducing if not eliminating
poverty
i'm going to start where the story began
in central australia
a man called yami lester an aboriginal
man was running a health service
eighty percent of what walked in the
door in terms of illness
was infectious disease
third world developing world infectious
disease caused by
a poor living environment
yummy assembled a team
in alice springs he got a medical doctor
he got
an environmental health guy any hand
selected
a team of local aboriginal people
to work on this project
yummy told us at that first meeting
there's no money
always a good start no money
you have six months
and i want you to start on a project
which in his language he called yuwan
karapalian kukaninjaku
which translated is a plan to stop
people getting sick a profound brief
that was our task
first step the medical doctor went away
for about six months
and he worked on what would have become
these nine health goals what were we
aiming at
after six months of work he came to my
office and presented me with
those
nine words on a piece of paper
now i was very very unimpressed
come on
big ideas need big words and preferably
a lot of them
this didn't fit the bill
what i didn't see and what
you can't see
was that he
assembled thousands of pages
of local national and international
health research
that filled out the picture as to why
these were the health targets
the pictures that came a bit later
had a very simple reason the aboriginal
people who are our bosses and the senior
people
were most commonly illiterate so the
story had to be told in pictures of what
were these goals we worked with the
community
not telling them what was going to
happen in a language they didn't
understand
so we had the goals
and each one of these goals and i won't
go through them all
puts at the center the person
and their health issue
and it then connects them
to the bits of the physical environment
that are actually needed
to keep their health good
and the highest priority you see on the
screen is washing people once a day
particularly children
and i hope most of you are thinking what
that sounds simple
now
i'm going to ask you all a very personal
question
this morning before you came who could
have had
a wash using a shower
i'm not going to ask if you had a shower
because i'm too polite that's it
okay
all right i think it's fair to say most
people here could have had a shower this
morning i'm going to ask you to do some
more work i want you all to select one
of the houses of the 25 houses you see
on the screen i want you to select one
of them and note the position of that
house and keep that in your head have
you all got a house i'm going to ask you
to live there for a few months so make
sure you got it right it's in the
northwest of western australia very
pleasant place
okay let's see if your shower in that
house is working
i hear some oz and i hear some ah
if you get a green tick
your shower's working you and your kids
are fine if you get a red cross
well i've looked carefully around the
room and it's not going to make much
difference to this crew
why because you're all too old
and i know that's going to come as a
shock to some of you but you are
and before you get offended and leave
i've got to say that being too old in
this case means that
pretty much everyone in the room i think
is over five years of age
we're really concerned with kids naught
to five and why
washing is the antidote to the sort of
bugs the common infectious diseases of
the eyes the ears the chest
and the skin
that if they occur in the first five
years of life permanently damage
those organs
they leave a lifelong remnant
that means that by the age of five you
can't see as well for the rest of your
life you can't hear as well for the rest
of your life
you can't breathe as well you've lost a
third of your lung capacity by the age
of five
and even skin infection which we
originally thought wasn't that big a
problem
mild skin infections naught to five give
you a greatly increased chance of renal
failure needing dialysis at age 40.
this is a big deal so the ticks and
crosses on the screen are actually
critical for young kids
those ticks and crosses represent the 7
800 houses we've looked at nationally
around australia the same proportion
what you see on the screen 35 of those
not so famous houses lived in by 50 000
indigenous people
35 had a working shower
10 of those same 7 800 houses had safe
electrical systems
and 58
of those houses had a working toilet
these are by a simple standard test in
the case of the shower
does it have hot and cold water two taps
that work
a shower rose to get water onto your
head or onto your body and a drain that
takes the water away not well designed
not beautiful not elegant just that they
function and the same tests for the
electrical system and the toilets
housing health projects aren't about
measuring failure they're actually about
improving houses
we start
on day one of every project we've
learned we don't make promises we don't
do reports
we arrive in the morning with
tools tons of equipment
trades and we train up a local team on
the first day to start work by the
evening of the first day a few houses in
that community are better than when we
started in the morning
that work continues for six to twelve
months until all the houses are improved
and we've spent our budget of seven and
a half thousand dollars total per house
that's our average budget
at the end of six months to a year we
test every house again
it's very easy to spend money it's very
difficult
to improve the function of all those
parts of a house and for a whole house
the nine healthy living practices we
test check and fix 250 items in every
house
and these are the results we can get
with our seven and a half thousand
dollars we can get showers up to 86
percent working we can get electrical
systems up to 77 percent working and we
can get 90 percent of toilets working in
those seven and a half thousand houses
thank you
the teams do a great job and that's
their work
i think there's an obvious question
that i hope you're thinking about
why do we have to do this work why are
the houses in such poor condition
seventy percent of the work we do is due
to lack of routine maintenance the sort
of things that happen in all our houses
things wear out
should have been done by state
government or local government simply
not done
the house doesn't work 21 of the things
we fix are due to faulty construction
literally things that are built upside
down and back to front they don't work
we have to fix them
and if you've lived in australia in the
last 30 years
the final cause
you will have heard always that
indigenous people trash houses it's one
of the almost rock-solid pieces of
evidence which i've never seen evidence
for that's always reeled out as that's
the problem with indigenous housing well
nine percent of what we spend is damage
misuse or abuse of any sort
we argue strongly that the people living
in the house are simply not the problem
and we'll go a lot further than that the
people living in the house are actually
a major part of the solution
of our national team in australia over
75 at the minute
are actually local indigenous people
from the communities we work in
they do all aspects of the work
in 2010 for example there were 831
all over australia and the torres strait
islands all states working to improve
the houses where they and their families
live and that's an important thing
our work's always had a focus on on
health that's the key
the developing world bug trachoma causes
blindness it's a developing world
illness and yet the picture you see
behind is an aboriginal community in the
late 1990s
where 95 percent of school-age kids had
active trachoma in their eyes doing
damage
okay what do we do
well first thing we do
we get showers working why because that
flushes the bug out we put washing
facilities in the school as well so kids
can wash their faces many times during
the day we wash the bug out
second the eye doctors tell us that dust
scours the eye and lets the bug in quick
so what do we do we call up the doctor
of dust and there is such a person
he was loaned to us by a mining company
he controls dust on mining company sites
and he came out and within a day it
worked out that most dust in this
community was within a metre of the
ground the wind driven dust so he
suggested making mounds to catch the
dust before it went into the house area
and affected the eyes of kids so we used
dirt
to stop dust we did it he provided us
dust monitors we tested and we reduced
the dust then we wanted to get rid of
the bug generally so how do we do that
well we call up the doctor of flies and
yes there is a doctor of flies
as our aboriginal mate said you white
fellas ought to get out more
um
and the doctor of flies very quickly
determined that
there was one fly that carried the bug
he could give school kids in this
community the beautiful fly trap you see
above in the slide
they could trap the flyers send them to
him in perth
when the bug was in the gut he'd send
back by return post some dung beetles
the dung beetles ate the camel dung
the flies died through lack of food and
trachoma dropped and over the year
took home had dropped radically in this
place and stayed low we did we changed
the environment not just treated the
eyes
and finally you get a good eye
all these small health gains and and
small pieces of the puzzle make a big
difference in new south wales department
of health that radical organization did
an independent trial
over three years to look at 10 years of
the work we've been doing in these sorts
of projects in new south wales and they
found a 40
reduction in hospital admissions for the
illnesses that you could attribute to
the poor environment a 40
reduction
just to show that the principles we've
used in australia can be used in other
places i'm just going to go to one other
place that's nepal and what a beautiful
place to go
we were asked by a small village of 600
people to go in and make toilets
where none existed health was poor
we went in with no grand plan no grand
promises of a great program just the
offer to build two toilets for two
families it was during the design of the
first toilet
that i went for lunch invited by the
family into their main room of the house
it was choking with smoke people were
cooking on their only fuel source green
timber the smoke coming off that timber
is choking in an enclosed house you
simply can't breathe
later we found the leading cause of
illness and death in this particular
region is through respiratory failure so
all of a sudden we had two problems we
were there originally to look at toilets
and get human waste off the ground
that's fine but all of a sudden now
there was a second problem
how do we actually get the smoke down so
two problems and design should be about
more than one thing
solution
take human waste take animal waste put
it into a chamber out of that extract
biogas methane gas
the gas gives three to four hours
cooking a day clean smokeless and free
for the family
[Music]
i put it to you is this eliminating
poverty and the answer from the nepali
team who's working at the minute would
say don't be ridiculous we have three
million more toilets to build before we
could even make
a stab at that claim and i don't pretend
anything else but as we all sit here
today
there are now over 100 toilets built in
this village and a couple nearby
well over a thousand people use those
toilets
yummy llama
he's a young boy he's got significantly
less gut infection because he's now got
toilets and there isn't human waste on
the ground
kajiman
she's a mother and a proud one she's
probably right now cooking lunch for her
family
on biogas smokeless fuel her lungs have
got better and they'll get better as
time increases because she's not cooking
in the same smoke
surya takes the waste out of the biogas
chamber when it's shed the gas he puts
it on his crops he's trebled his crop
income more food for the family and more
money for the family and finally bishnu
the
the leader of the team has now
understood that not only have we built
toilets we've also built
a team and that team is now working in
two villages where they're training up
the next two villages to keep the work
expanding and that to me is the key
[Music]
people are not the problem
we've never found that the problem poor
living environment
poor housing and the bugs that do people
harm
none of those are limited by geography
by skin color or by religion
none of them
the common link between all the work
we've had to do is one thing and that's
poverty
nelson mandela said in the mid 2000s not
too far from here he said that like
slavery and apartheid
poverty is not natural
it's man-made
and can be overcome and eradicated by
the actions of human beings
i want to end by saying it's been the
actions
of
thousands of ordinary human beings doing
i think extraordinary work that have
actually improved health
and maybe only in a small way reduce
poverty thank you very much for your
time
[Music]
you